yoga's with the procedure again oh there
we go all right so I'm back in the same
line pixel hub hub 9 pixel com a server
set and build time oh this is
interesting what do we do oh I think I
get what we do all right so this is turf
wars and the objective of this is to
something this my first time ever
playing it so yeah we're going to be
going going hard in the projects as we
do as we do and I'm gonna I'm gonna
follow that guy's lead oh no i'm not i'm
going to make and then i'm going to hide
right here make some connecting and then
yeah that we go okay haier brand okay
that guy drew first blood all right away
stood an arrow okay uh so this looks
like basically super paintball and I
don't yeah so I get arrows after some
time so let's let's see if I can snipe
that boy oh gotta watch out for these
people so yeah striker had just actually
um peaced out peace out the homeboys he
got off since I don't know what time it
is whoa that guy killed with our tree
combat at time one point one minute's
wait am I can i still fight can I nope
oh I can't fight okay okay Billy's no I
got but you can I fight I'm confused
number time oh um I got killed or Sri
again oh this doesn't make sense let's
see let's break down that guy's barrier
why do I water my thing comes back why
is it bouncing back bro well this is
annoying I don't mind anything has been
sent back Oh pop uh I can't fully
charged it I I confuses heck be a
striker peaced out and so as you can see
these were all record one day I'm just
trying to get a bunch of videos recorded
so that I can
post them because i'll be leaving too
i'll be going out of town for a few days
and this guy's attacking my team oh
that's like I'm gonna save my team and
he's like no you're not you're gonna get
killed and let's go I'll fail pop Oh pop
she could pop who I killed gotta kill
you guys okay it's we're getting pwned
so that's not good you cannot attack
darn Oh bill time has begun oh gotta
rebuild okay built on bill time bill
done place place place place place place
place place that was terrible a place
place place place place place place
place place so you can just combat time
for four days so let's try breaking down
this guy's barrier okay so so we get me
good oh that ice nut my head and yes
there's a little this is called turf
wars as you can tell and otima no no get
out of your big boy oh I'm failing oh oh
there we go so basically I've only
killed fire and ice because I'm the best
and they have us push back into her like
spawn come on come on tonight Oh like a
and my bow shot didn't even receive oh
why is the red line why is the redline
push so far oh my gosh that this round
they've gone 50 kills we've gotten six
oh this is terrible oh this is this is
horrible they went okay retching one all
right um yeah so this was gorgeous we'll
do another round of this on our 200 is
in it actually just just try a different
minigame so yeah well this is just uh
basically because I found this I'm going
to be doing tons more let's try some
super paintball that sounded pretty cool
okay kicked Wells connecting okay well I
was kicked ball dragon escape dragons
played that plate that snake when the
quiver turf wars I put all those this is
the only mini a that I haven't placed oh
there we go nice got it i joined the
another team awesome alright the game
started by up soon so this will be good
so as these because i found all these
i'm going to
be posting a lot more of this stuff so
this will be something I can basically
post every day if I want to and
hopefully i will I know I've said a lot
but i do want to post more so paintball
rifle this is super paper water bottom
oh it's free for all now it's a
free-for-all where you have teamed I'm
on another team oh ok that's another
team so shoot oh wow they have like
shotguns and I have normal temple all
right let's go for the Tao let's go for
the tower I like let's shoot at these
guys ok let's go let's go let's go let's
go Oh teammate Timmy I got you I got
your teammate ooh pwned phone in his
face ok do I have a certain amount of
like oh oh go down Oh below this is this
like a like shut down stuff for what or
that his teammate I was teammate get
painted I don't know what like what am I
supposed to do this oh I feel like oh we
want ha I was really short game alright
well this is just a little bit of intro
to each of the game types so yeah I've
played a few other ones I guess you guys
haven't seen excitement record but I
think I'll end with my app all right
guys yeah I hope you have all enjoyed
and as i said be on the lookout for the
new series coming up i'll be also
recording that after i get back so
that'll be some time after this upcoming
sunday alright guys hope you enjoy this
if you did actually live like right tom
and or subscribe shot and i'll see you
all later peace
I look at the baby